welcome to this video playing rah yeah
this is alex reprints f i'm not mistaken
and I can he went g FOIA this guy is a
complete maniac always playing wild
openings usually you're like winning
after 10 to 50 moves but then yeah it
gets complicated and murky and whatnot
so let's see what happens I'm just
trying with normal stuff normal moves
again this is G for business developing
and so on maybe Bishop c5 at the right
moment currently it's attacking g7 so
that's not so easily possible Queen B 6
yeah that's a bit dull but anyway yeah
it's got 94 let's say that's not great
him okay that's not exactly a refutation
office g4 opening why does somewhat
better him slightly better in dr. G for
you should have an advantage with black
but Heather said didn't play it well I
need to need to trade some stuff well
he's got a very high rating compared to
what he usually has I mean it's not like
he's a bad player so it's just that this
is really i mean is usually around the
2200 so came
what is the big point here I check this
and then what I can also take you six
and then he
I don't get it what is the big idea I
mean now this isn't a bad position for
me at all when I wrong maybe I'm wrong I
mean I'm instruct from a structural
point of view I'm porn up now with this
we adult porn seemed fairly are
necessary why it was just slightly
better with no particular problem okay
if I go there maybe route before for
tempo
just you want to push to push g5 even
more you know g5 myself is not a
particularly great idea so Knight f6
what is he doing look before I what
probably
yeah I need to that can trade one pair
of roots in this position I'm just very
very fine but i don't know if i get to
do that so easily trying for up to a
drupe t1 jack is no this okay now look
here is actually a rock trade yes Bishop
g6 down which doesn't feel particularly
threatening Kings Teague's
I don't say root get made yeah let's go
to get made
I won't ever I really don't understand
anything I just think he's playing for
loss here this is this whole game I mean
this isn't just good for black I don't
know take through care for some LT group
d for ya so I take and what's your point
and cheek age 6 i'll just take
everything I mean you just place for
technical trick so you have to be always
alert jinx there
so let's do this
ok
I am somewhat done on time this is a bit
a bit annoying
check-check time warning they just place
always like the typical drunken machine
gunner style just firing firing firing
and hoping that it works sometimes it
does often it does not but yeah it's
always difficult to play in such a
player because I always place aggressive
moves never never passive one or
whatever and sometimes it works here I'm
just getting this pawn & age 5 is also
an also problem
I know is taking some time look at three
maybe yeah to prevent to prevent this
how can you not take this move okay
didn't see that at all okay it just
looks like a self in situ or recruit be
7 p-7 maybe Jack 95 is godrick this
seven okay better to be lucky than good
one so let's see can I promote this to
this thing
check check check check check check
check ah come on I have no time like for
its entirety for very long time yes
stuff you were just playing this far too
aggressively and here it's probably
equal still I mean if anybody can do
something is of course black because
white stone structures so awful and I
have that power so Luke trades or
something would be just great for me but
I first started to get in our blundered
bishop age 70 Wow look at age haha
Bishop age 7 and a result oops yeah now
everything is fine again this this was
almost really weird anyway okay so i was
still shy pushing everything Janet yeah
no I don't know mean he has no pawn
structure whatsoever but I took you five
is probably ok and now yeah and maybe I
could have taken age five immediately
with that it should be a win somehow
ok up to here the comp doesn't check
criticize my move so I mean I saw that
of course but i was thinking yeah here
until about stupid right Genesis the
winner still have this pawn it's a
complete win ok but I think this should
win as well chan yeah it does win it
does when check so at the end decent
game but I was very lucky it could
affirm check chan he could have played
this Bishop age seven move ok well
thanks for watching